a lot of ladies get a little
self-conscious a little embarrassed I
say queef it up sister it's nice to see
that thing talking for
once love a queef big fan of the queef I
went down a girl once she queefed my
hair
went it's a hell of a time you got to be
empathetic to the que fellas because
ladies I think you're more empathetic in
general I think you're more thoughtful
you think about others men we don't
think about others we think about
ourselves like I'll go to dinner with my
girl she like we can't eat here heard
the chef's homophobic I'm like great
we're not gay we're good yeah that's how
I think man we don't think about others
I was watching a tenants match with my
buddy I go you know this guy went to
jail for hitting his wife my friend goes
oh yeah he's got a great backand Jesus
Christ you're a little deeper ladies a
little more emotionally intelligent like
you ever ask a woman what she likes in a
guy she'll tell you what she likes
because of how it makes her feel I like
how he's big and strong cuz I feel safe
I like guys got some money cuz I feel
taken care of guys we just tell you what
we like we don't tell how we feel we
like a woman Bob like a fat
ass how's it make you feel hard I don't
know